Great job.
By this point you have started to
analyze the problems that exist in your
company.
Throughout the standard degree, we'll
dive deeper into typical problems faced
by companies and
come up with potential solutions.
In the process,
you'll learn about spinning up
virtual machines in the cloud,
using configuration management software,
managing microservices, and more.
In the meantime, make sure to submit
Projects Zero for review and feedback.
Now DevOps is all about
communication and collaboration.
We put this into practice when
building this nano-degree.
We have people from Udacity and Google,
people from operations, development,
project management, who agreed to
lend their expertise to the program.
That said,
it's time to hear from someone new.
I'm going to pass you along
to my colleague, Carl.
>> Hi, I'm Carl,
a course developer here at Udacity.
In the next lesson,
we'll talk more about the history
of dev ops in the Combs Model.
See you soon.